[Musique]
il est ok là parfois faire enterrer les
bons et les bons airs il eric et
l'accueil des moteurs autre biais
alors oui parce qu'il a dit merci d'être
là mais le concept a annoncé une heure
sur un plateau et qui insulte une femme
moi j'appelle pas ça un homme
personnellement et un homme c'est bien
de leurs pleurs et anne c'est très loin
d'un petit bayonne
moi je bois moi j'ai l'air de rigoler
mal à manger une annonce à faire c'est
moi qui attendais à temps c'est moi qui
ai la parole pour l'instant je tiens à
reconnaître des tubes honnête avec
toboggan sylvie les sur le personnage et
mes frères je vais le réaliser par email
autres pendant les dix un tribunal où le
cas où il arrive il me fait ça et moi ce
que son corps à nabeul compris tout le
monde
ils m'ont trimestre sans portable on
peux pas m'empêcher d'y montrer en bas
de chez toi qui est risible
il montre son portable comme ça en
pleurant
il est beau il est beau il est bon thé
risible c'est là les larmes du concept
très mal entouré
il maintient son compte comme taipei où
j'ai fait péter les followers
tu as fait tomber tes lunettes ça ne
regarde pas alors tombé tard nature
reprendrons notre sérieux on prend notre
calme alors émis qu'est-ce qui se passe
bon alors tout d'abord je tiens à
reconnaître que je me suis emporté dans
votre émission et que ce n'est pas ma
façon d'errer il a un truc à dire où est
passée la culotte cd de loana et voilà
on va laisser le temps de guerre j'amène
pas dans ma patrie du suivi on va
écouter ce qu'il a dit à tous vous
répondrais ya pas de premières silice
voilà mais après tu n'es pas précisé si
le plus évident et c'est le pari mais
sylvie arrêter sinon sinon sylvie benoît
les silhouettes en ligne
c'est toi qui m'aiment bien de sortie
[Musique]
allez vous de ce soir était d'ailleurs
ce que tu as osé dire hier soir c'est
d'aller voir mon mari harry ellis est ce
que la balise des gagnants
c'est une nuitée
il veut même pas il veut même pas logées
à metz de ces deux east room c'est au ps
obliger les le truc s'il vous plaît
sylvie la radio on est en direct
on aimerait vraiment que ça se passe
bien avec son intérim pour leur examen
ce soir il a été digne avec moi je te
connais mieux c'est l'essentiel donc
merrill ces vers la halle et dire je
reprends mon cas oui d'abord je tiens à
reconnaître que je me suis emporté dans
votre émission et que ce n'est pas ma
façon d'être
ni mon éducation de maxime jurassien
yoplait mais j'étais très proche de mon
père est de savoir qu'une personne comme
elle qu'elle se dénigrer ma famille et
tout particulièrement mon père qui est
décédé en 2013 en utilisant les réseaux
sociaux m'a été insupportable
je pense que beaucoup d'entre vous qui
ont le respect de la famille peuvent me
comprendre tout le monde pleure regarde
avec précis vie si mal non je
souhaiterais récupérer les affaires de
loana à ses bijoux et les cartes de
crédit pas tout ce que tu as bellegarde
et grédy une blague que je puisse les
lui rendre
le dernier message à transmettre de
loana lorena aimerait que tu désactive
le comte tik tok tu as créé à son nom
alors le renard
il ya eu un vide
alors délaissé le fener les clc la
transition va devoir être les mêmes mais
cap maintenant leur cible héricy merci
quant à moi j'ai fait de mon mieux ont
des lois na waie l'ayant ces
informations car elle était si on a la
capacité de le faire
t'as même pas voulu du gène évidemment
c'est bon c'est bon on peut toujours
compter sur mon soutien et sauf si elle
me le demande je n'ai plus de messages à
transmettre de sa part je tiens à
remercier monsieur cyril hanouna et la
production de tpe pour avoir donné par
mon intermédiaire la parole à loana pour
qu'elle puisse se défendre et bien
évidemment je remercie les nombreux
internautes pour leur soutien est ce que
je voudrais dire c'est que moi le renard
ça fait plus de dix ans qu'on est amis
on s'est engueulés loana et moi on s'est
aussi frites et je suis vous conseillons
s'effriter mais pas content ya une chose
que moi émergent a montré la nycturie
d'argent ça monte moyens surtout je n'ai
jamais été avec loana seville et c'est
de finir qu'on a qu'on est pas gêné
c'est fini on sait plus discutés durant
sanctuaire des fonds s'effriter voilà
c'est pourquoi on vous 10 ans et demi
nous on est toujours amis ambarès
surtout qu'elle traite de con il n'ya
pas longtemps parce que moi en rapport à
toi
où est mon ami fred commun je n'ai
jamais traité dans la boue comme vous
faites dans les faits j'avais jamais
traité dans la boue comme toi tu fais
avec fred corral oui non les réseaux
sociaux je n'ai plus à parler à cette
personne n'est d'accord